[Music]
Halloween 2018 our David Gordon greens
Halloween or the the new one whatever
it's called Halloween 1.5 it makes sense
because the first two-thirds of this
movie is essentially a remake and then
everything that's original that
culminates by the end of the movie is
terrible but I guess we'll talk about
that later I guess we will
spoilers we didn't really like the movie
that much it was disappointing not a
terrible film you know I I don't want to
sit here and say like this is Halloween
resurrection or you know Halloween 3
season of the witch or something we
really get into some spoilers we're
gonna talk about spoilers because I've
already reviewed the film you know it
wasn't really for me but there's so much
that I wanted to cover that I just
couldn't I could don't like it only
really hint at it like certain things
that occur breakdown the plot basically
a bus crashes and Michael Myers escapes
and he starts killing people on
Halloween night again there is there's
not really much significance to it which
is fine you know a Halloween movie
should be simple but I think my biggest
issue with the movie is that it just it
felt very unfocused it would go from
moments of really odd placed comedy to
Michael Myers is killing people to a
backstory with a granddaughter a
backstory with a daughter and a
backstory with the grandmother Laurie
Strode who I thought was gonna be kind
of the main character of the film but to
be honest she kind of felt secondary to
like the high school character yeah I
agree I wanted more Jamie Lee Curtis and
the movie didn't need anyone else
besides Jamie Lee Curtis
you had the insignificant granddaughter
who is the teenager of the movie and
once again this movie is just pretty
much taking what the original movie did
and finding a way to kind of just place
it in this movie but it doesn't quite
feel right the way the shoehorn it in
there yeah it felt like there were
sequences that were straight out of the
first Halloween and one in particular
from Halloween - which is actually in
the second trailer it's this really long
shot of him bumping into two
trick-or-treaters and he walks into a
garage gets a hammer then he kills a
woman
there's a sequence just like that in the
opening of Halloween - it's a great
tracking shot yeah no I mean it's good
it's well done but like it just felt so
much like what we had already seen
before but then there were other scenes
that were like kind of very shaky and
close-up and you know that was like
where David Gordon Green felt kind of
more like the movies I've seen from him
before like Joe with Nicholas Cage
he has such a strange filmography like
he made your highness and the sitter and
then he makes like human tragedy movies
like stronger exactly and you know but
the thing I will say about him as a
director as far as like understanding
Jamie Lee Curtis is emotions and Michael
Myers emotions and getting those two
characters right as a director they
picked the right guy yeah for everything
else they put they picked the wrong guy
yeah I really don't know if it was the
right choice and I know that plenty of
people will disagree I just I feel like
maybe a more seasoned horror director
like someone likes a James Wan oh that
would be great could you imagine those
visuals I would have been pretty cool I
think yeah I think it would've been
something special the only thing I loved
about this movie there like you said
earlier sometimes they recreate what the
original did visually with the tracking
shots there's like one shot of the
granddaughter running on this desolated
Street but they're just recreating these
scenes yeah that was the best part about
this movie everything original that they
brought to it is underwhelming yeah and
that's not to say that I think they
should have just done the same thing
again that's actually I think what
you're saying is it's disappointing yeah
that the best parts of the movie were
the rehash parts yes yes yes I did like
how they they took things from the
original and sort of switched and
swapped things like the granddaughter
looks outside of the class and instead
of seeing Michael there she sees Laurie
they're my favorite little moment in the
movie was when Laurie falls down yeah
you know she's on the ground and
Michael's looking down at her and then
she's gone I was like oh shit that's
pretty much you know like another swap
moment from the first movie and I love
the idea of Laurie kind of becoming the
predator in that scene and Michael's the
prey like the the roles get swapped and
that's a really interesting thing to do
with this movie
and that's about where the things that I
loved kind of end yeah well let's talk
about the things that we hate him now
those start yeah um ripoff dr. Loomis oh
my god was probably the worst character
I've seen in a horror film ever I hated
the character before the big twist thing
oh he was creepier and scarier than
Michael Myers has ever been I I'm like
how is that guy a doctor and why does
anyone trust anything that he's saying
even Laurie Strode says you're the new
Loomis yes
blatantly puts it out there's like the
most meta moment
ever yes this character is pointless in
the film really beyond some some really
crazy third-act twist I'll get into in a
second but every single time to cut back
to him I just kept thinking to myself
why is he in this movie why didn't he
just die on that bus no I do we keep
having the replacement limit you're not
gonna replace Donald Pleasence no so
just don't don't try you know like it's
a smart thing to not try and they tried
and no we got this guy we got this dude
I mentioned it in my review there's a
moment that was just so baffling to me
and when the film ended I think you my
wife and our other friend we all looked
at each other and we were like what was
with that like can anyone explain that
and basically the one cop in the film
will Patton's character yeah
he hits Michael Myers with his car and
he gets out and checks if he's dead or
whatever and I remember from the first
moment of that that scene with a doctor
he said something like oh you killed him
I was like he's dead I was like good
that's the point yeah why are you so mad
and then he has like a retractable
penknife yes he goes like it goes and a
knife comes out of his fucking pen and
he just stabs the cop like a billion
times in the face and he just kind of
takes over the night and says like hey
Michael let's experiment more with what
you can do very forced contrived and
terribly written
I hated it plus is a doctor this guy's
been a doctor for 45 years right a
psychologist working a normal job just
one day
says I'm gonna start killing people for
what that's what I said afterwards it
wasn't clever I was starting to a buddy
and I was like what was his plan for
tomorrow yeah I'll go back to work no
yeah this cop car has no camera it would
have been ok if he was a little bit
creepy and and he had that mentality
that he wanted to see what Michael would
do if he was unleash that's fine if he
would have just sat back in the
background and allowed it to happen but
actually interacting and killing people
that's that's not clever and even in the
beginning of the movie when the bus
crashes again I'm thinking that's
convenient can people not like how did
that happen but now that you know the
doctor probably provoked that situation
it makes sense but there are things that
it makes a little more sense like in the
opening scene were the two journalists
what I'll talk about in a second are
antagonizing Michael holding that mask I
was thinking like this is this doesn't
make sense but you know if the doctor is
is in some way like experimenting with
like the boundaries of evil or whatever
then okay then that makes sense but I do
not believe that any as you said decades
long trained experienced doctor would
throw a teenage girl in the back of a
police car with Michael Myers just to
see what happens it's just stupid well
we already know what's gonna happen
Michael Myers likes to fucking kill
people he's probably going to fucking
kill people yeah but the worst part of
this whole thing is is that within a
minute
Michael ryan gosling drives the guy's
head and it's just done yeah they just
completely throw it away
he stops the guy's head into mush and
that's it so we had like this random
horrific twist that existed for exactly
two minutes and then they just threw it
away it's like they shot the scene yeah
was like oh shit this doesn't make any
sense
forget about it obviously that's not
what happened they wrote it and they
filmed it but like that's what it feels
like it just feels like this very
throwaway moment that was so maddening
and unnecessary and then they do they
don't even follow through no I think it
ran its course as far as it possibly
could and speaking of that doctors head
that squishes so easily like like a
shirt yeah like a balloon with spaghetti
like what like heads dumb
squish like that trust me I know Chris I
know - yeah that one day mm-hmm in the
back alley we don't speak of that no
sorry I still remember the screams when
I close my eyes to go back to those
journalists that were so inept I think
they were podcasters he said that yeah
he did say he's like I run a podcast I
was a podcast she's like we're
investigative journalists I was okay
which one is it yeah yeah so maybe
they're both within the first five
minutes of this movie where they first
have their interaction with Michael
Myers I knew this wasn't gonna be that
clever well-written thought-out
Halloween movie that I was hoping it was
going to be really for the simple fact
of one of the podcasters this guy makes
fucking podcast right he pulls out
Michael Myers original mask keep in mind
this is evidence from a serial killer
this is like you don't just pick this up
he says he has a friend at the attorney
general's office so you're telling me
this guy oh I got a friend who makes
podcasts let me just go to the evidence
room and pull out that that serial
killers mask room 40 years ago and here
you go buddy well John you know I really
have to say as someone who's made videos
and content on the internet for almost a
decade now I have a lot of friends in
the police department
sure yeah tons of people constantly give
me access to to government you know
property and evidence and yes paperwork
yes all the time
oh yeah it's like why not here you need
a prop this was used in the murder of a
nine-year-old little girl in Wichita
Kansas but hey you got it for your video
so that's awesome just make sure you
return it when you're done in all
seriousness those journalists were
literally in the film to give us
exposition about the backstory that the
majority of the audience already knew
most of the time is literally them just
Infanta cailli stating the backstory and
to give him his mask that's it they were
there to give him his mask there's so
much screentime dedicated to them which
is so strange to me because they also
try to set up this high school romance
in a love triangle where where the girl
has a boy she likes and then there's
another boy that kind of likes her but
he doesn't
admit it yet she goes to a dance and
what does she see the boy making out
with another girl so that's not good
that's very sad I literally just saw
this scene in goosebumps - the exact
scenes really pumps - the exact scene a
girl likes a boy they're kind together
she goes to a club and she sees the boy
making out with another girl and she
gets jealous and she runs off exact
scene I mean it is one of the most
cliched highschool romance things I've
ever seen
granted Halloween 1978 is not some
masterpiece of writing it's just a
really well-crafted horror film but it
doesn't waste your time no it does a
viewer everything is to the point and I
will say this before we jump into that I
do want to talk about the original but
the only reason that that love triangle
existed was to get rid of her her cell
phone
I said you threw it in the chip dip yeah
and now no one can call her and that's
one of my biggest issue with this movie
is the the screenwriting is actually
kind of really lazy like the characters
they're journalists they're there to
give a sex position and to give Michael
the mask that entire thing is to get rid
of her cell phone so no one can call her
yeah I mean when your characters exist
purely to be plot devices that propel
the plot along without really being
people that's what they come off like
and that's exactly what they come off
like in this movie I know nothing about
the journalists I don't care about the
journalists I don't care about the
teenagers and granted like there's a
thing with slasher movies where
everyone's kind of a disposable possible
victim that Michael could kill and I get
that it just doesn't really do anything
for me really see I have a critique that
would fix two issues of this movie and
want to simplified everything and took
20 minutes out of the screen Tucker the
crazy doctor let's just say he has the
mask in evidence and gives it to Michael
Myers early on in the movie so we don't
need the journalist the granddaughter of
Laurie Strode she's running away from
Michael earlier in the movie drops her
phone boom do things done you know you
don't need all this other crap movie
yeah even the scene of like the teens
walking through the suburbia which was
straight out of carpenters original that
scene was basically there to set the
characters up but also to give more
exposition where somebody is like hey
wasn't Michael Myers Laurie's brother or
something and they're like no that was a
myth somebody made up to feel better
about themselves
we're not stupid okay we've heard you
say a thousand times over you're
forgetting about the other Halloween
sequences I get it they're not siblings
anymore they're not related it's just
there are so many scenes like that where
I felt like I was being talked to like a
little kid yeah
instead of presented a compelling
narrative the most frustrating thing
about this movie was when I was watching
it I kept comparing it to the original
film which is only fair it's a
essentially a ting a direct sequel and
from a technical standpoint a
cinematography standpoint and an
atmospheric standpoint the original is
superior in every single way it even has
a better score and soundtrack yeah than
what they were able to do in this movie
which that movie was made for a
low-budget 40 years ago yeah why is it
better in every way
even the opening shot in the original
Halloween that that tracking shot that
he'll be tracking shot that shot alone
is better than any shot in this new
movie it still gives me chills when I
watch it take James Wan for instance you
know he made a lot of horror films he
made SAW he made dead silence which
wasn't really that good
insidious cities to the conjuring
conjuring 2 he knows the genre back in
front I mean but he also knows like what
horror fans have seen a thousand times
and this movie tends to think well
Michael Myers is walking around a street
and there are trick-or-treaters so
that's good enough and there isn't
really that scene that I recall is like
wow that really had me white-knuckled
like that was really intense
the closest device that they kind of had
that I thought was pretty interesting
were the searchlights in that scene
where Michael was like getting closer
and closer to the kid as the lights went
on and off I was just thinking about
that one of the issues though is that I
just I did not give one single shit
about this kid and I was like just get
it over with just kill him let's do it
please get it over with
there were also scenes that were just
straight out of other movies we already
talked about some of the tracking shots
but the bathroom
death where Michael ran
he takes someone's teeth and drops the
teeth in front of me on that was pretty
much just like h2o I mean nice exactly
burst into a bathroom and kills the
woman where else does he get a
mechanic's jump though Chris exactly
let's talk about those teeth for just a
second sure um why why do you think he
did that now in this film's defense
michael has shown a flair for the
theatrical atiba for like in the first
one he takes the Judith's reduction the
intercounty and deception are powerful
agents to the uninitiated initiated man
were nerds maybe he was gonna make a
necklace with the teeth like in Jurassic
world necklace that was a plot point
yeah movie it was but seriously like in
the first Halloween
he took Judith's grave and he put it on
that bed yeah you know he came in that
one room with the sheet on like he has
like a weird kind of trickster mentality
so I get that like he's like I'm gonna
scare this woman with these teeth I
remember even when I saw in the trailer
I was like what's he doing with the
teeth did he just kill that guy and just
kind of like take out his teeth and then
punch him a few times take some tea and
then go on I'm gonna drop it rating for
that woman what did seem like Michael
Myers in this movie and they showed a
few times he likes to rip people's jaws
off yeah and then in this movie and I
don't know maybe over the years he got
some kind of weird fetish for teeth and
open the jaws off people I don't know
he's just sitting there in his mental
institution thinking about like I can't
wait to collect those days get those
teeth ma'am maybe he wants to be a
dentist but I do have a few positive
things I can say about the movie the
little kid
that's yes eating baby sat in the film
is the best character in the entire
movie I don't know why but you're right
and and he was a comic relief mm-hmm
that worked and felt right within this
film yes and I really liked that me too
I liked that kid
the girl was on the phone talking about
alacadabra or something Sam and he was
like you talk about weed aren't you I
know you talking about we Michaels in
the closet oh fuck that in walks it runs
away yeah Oh help
yeah that's funny that's very thick and
that should have been about the extent
maybe yeah you know but then you have
like two cops in a car and then guys
like this is a baguette sandwich that
was made specially for me it's it's very
important to have your nutrition in here
and then the guys he's like what do you
have he's like oh I got a brownie and
from Trago pudding I think as I go you
know you shouldn't have that for lunch
that's like for a five-year-old and I'm
like what what but then I have friends
at a Korean restaurant that made a
peanut butter and jelly baguette just
for you yeah it goes on for three
minutes it felt like an improv scene not
a very good one no I was just starting
to get into this what is happening why
are you talking about a fucking sandwich
and then five seconds later we get the
terrible plot twist of them yeah
which just that right there I knew it
was coming part of me knew that was
coming since the bus accident because I
was like why is he the only guy left
alive on this bus yeah and I was
thinking to myself though no they they
wouldn't do that no there's just so many
random moments like that where it felt
like they were being really funny I'm
trying to be trying to be funny and then
just doesn't have a place in the film it
takes you out of the experience it takes
you out of any tension
they wrote everyone to be really
unlikable in this movie except for
Laurie Strode yeah and I meant one kid
yes ever a little kid and you want
everyone to die in this movie a brutal
gruesome death I was like please Michael
Myers take their jaw and rip it off has
made what they were thinking you know
like will make everybody hate these
character forums so no one cares oh my
god
I forgot about the dad he also does
improv throughout the movie too he's
like there's this whole scene where he's
like I got peanut butter on my penis
yeah what like what is this watching sir
why are you having a scene about it and
it's like focused on a daughter she's
like dad
Oh dad stop talking about that it was
cringe-worthy yeah and he's
he's a he's a comedian but throughout
the whole movie he sort of is just like
is standing the background looking goofy
like there's like police and everyone's
like in this emergency emergency state
and he's just back there going no I
don't know what to do I don't know what
was happening I really there were some
miss casting going on you could say in
its defense they're taking a risk
they're trying to do something different
they're trying to insert comedy but you
know what I see I see studio decisions
I see somebody saying we have to have
young people in this movie we have to
have a high school dance we have to have
a love triangle drama we have to have
all of this because Halloween's a
slasher movie and that's that's the
demographic for it but wait to switch it
up Chris through one a big twist yes we
need the twists thrown a twist and
please have like comedy because
everybody loves Marvel movies whenever
whenever somebody's in a life-and-death
situation you know what they do they
tell jokes yeah they do they do that
time in that alley mm-hmm when we were
killing that guy yeah I was stomping his
head in yeah all I wanted to do was do a
stand-up comedy routine I wanted to get
peanut butter on my penis
I'm crying hold on talking about this
movie makes me want to a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich like that sounds good
another thing I did really like I did
like Judy Greer like she was like oh I
can't take the shot and Mike was like
okay fuck you and walks and she's like
gotcha and shoot something that's pretty
cool well and then like Lori's in the
background and the shadows and her face
and the shadows kind of like Michael
coming out of the shadows and the first
one and slicing their shoulder but like
this movie was advertised heavily as the
final confrontation where Lori will
finally kill Michael and she sets the
house on fire and you have this shot of
Michael standing there on the stairs and
then they're in the back of a truck and
you cut back to that exact spot and he's
gone he's gone and then inexplicably
they zoom in on the daughter holding a
bloody knife freeze-frame and then cut
to black are they saying she will be the
next character in this new franchise the
plum house will probably inevitably make
or are they suggesting that she will be
in some way impacted by this scenario go
down a dark path like what is that was
very off-putting to me they'll make
another one for sure but you know if you
wait until the very end of the credits
though eight minutes later you can hear
heavy breathing through a mask yeah we
sat through the credits right at the
very end so which is hey but we don't
know how the hell he did it he was
trapped in a basement and burned alive
which by the way Lawrence Rhodes planned
to kill Michael Myers was very
convoluted I did like how she had those
gates that shut off the rooms like okay
he's not in there shut the room like I
like that it was like okay we're
scratching that room yeah I'm scratching
that room off the list but no you're
right like there's so many ways that it
could have gone or not gone well okay
she has these giant spotlights on top of
her house which she decides to turn on
after he's in the house
she cages up every single window in the
house except for the two windows on the
front door where he inevitably grabs her
throat through them she has 28 guns in
her basement one of them is a fully you
know automatic assault rifle shotgun but
she picks up an old like revolver and
then she has this panic room in the
basement under this kitchen cupboard but
you could open it with like this garage
door opener but she leaves the garage
door opener on the counter where anyone
can just open it from upstairs so I just
don't get her her logic with anything
that she was actually doing yeah I can
understand it but it was really cool
like Skyfall no it was almost like the
same logic Kevin McCallister uses in
home alone it's like just get some paint
cans and micro machines and Christmas
bulbs it'll do the trick you give up
Michael are you thirsty and then Michael
hangs hangs Laurie Strode on the back of
a door he's a bite off every single time
the granddaughter of the casting choice
was okay she's just fine
Carolee written
like who they casted to be her actual
daughter I was really great who's also
in Jurassic world Reza rolia she just
felt miscast to me we had some really
dry readings yeah there's one line where
she's reminiscing about her childhood
and she's looking to the distancing I
used to shoot a gun and I didn't like it
and I'm reading off a cue card right now
like this is an outtake but they're
going to include it in the movie it felt
really bizarre I was like whoa what is
it happening right now you're right
you're right I wish I had the movie so
you glued that Club oh yes I did
it's exactly like that so disappointing
theda I wanted to love this movie I
really fucking dead dude I was like so
excited when it started I was fucking
there man I was already oh I was this I
this was my most anticipated movie of
October and I was like my whole life was
dedicated to watching this movie I was
very disappointed oh well that's
Halloween 2018 disappointing movie
disappointing I get that some people
really seem to like it I'm just not one
of those people I wanted more I wanted
more a few good ideas but overshadowed
by a lot of bad ones I agree well thanks
always for joining me thank you look
forward to more reviews in this section
of Halloween scary movies were going to
be doing this October thank you guys as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
you